olá josé é longa palestra chamadas
inscrições para tomar cuidados como usar
o portal hoje aqui das maiores
distâncias em dia só da faculdade
trabalhei social - disse falando com as
pessoas aqui não ficarão em uma unidade
uma favela
o volante chamou ainda os conselhos
estão correndo pela rua gritando você
pode acabar chegando com ela de maneira
a família muito grande em lei e já
contava com almoço café e cuidado mesmo
conversar sobre ações
você pode acabar esse braço da sua vida
a partir de hoje vocês fazem português e
deixar a unidade referência
cativa urgência medo em 2012
as faculdades não é só o primeiro ano na
reunião do centro de empreendedorismo
está a us negro chegar aqui falar da
oportunidade de trabalhar no
internacional de tecnologia social na
comunidade do brasil está a oportunidade
de chamar ficar falando está com certeza
se as comunidades na hora chegar
no brasil negros e nas subvenções por
título e chamou mais atenção
brasília junto com a apresentação do
problema a solução
quero trabalhar com o melhor computador
ensina os alunos a falar o que
o melhor comentário ele tinha um
ambiente muito a falta de tempo sobre o
dia era comentado
a gente começou a trabalhar começou a
desenvolver mais fácil de pentear legal
a gente podia fazer esse salto a gente
podia fazer com que a criança precisa
muito irritado com pergunta e acabou
dando tudo foi um pouco de açúcar
mas a gente não vai sair abaixo hora a
gente vai começar do zero
só que dessa vez vai começar a chegar um
pouco mais sobre como é a da manhã
a surpresa foi grande de ouro e ele me
chamou pra ajudar e ele disse para a
gente sair e vou realizar um sonho da
comunidade é só passar com essa opção já
tinha perdido né
eu acreditei na causa e agora ela tomou
à força o que a gente ia fazer um jogo
chamado oásis o jogo de casamento
comunitário onde a gente tentava
entender qual é a sefaz beleza da
comunidade e realizar um sonho comum
foi durante um sonho a gente podia
faltar em uma árvore
a comunidade faz efetiva só aquele jogo
que é a ciência enquanto os adultos é um
total de 79 edital que a gente podia
fazer nada
as crianças não tinham problema nenhuma
imagem na partida no lugar de fabricar
imaginar quadras crianças que acreditar
no nosso trabalho foi por aquilo que a
gente confiou e acreditou que a gente
poderia fazer um pac na comunidade
depois foi forte um final de semana
a gente conseguiu construir um pouquinho
pessoas todas as cidades algumas pessoas
andarem
não vi a imagem da gente
foi o caso das crianças existe esse jogo
tinha que continuar aquilo foi fazer do
sonho delas exigiu a intervenção de um
jeito de vestir pela gratidão
a gente e facebook podem sentir pra
gente
foi a partir desse jogo e ordem de a
terceira edição
temos uma unidade que tem quem não goste
motivação atênção bassiana as crianças
que têm esperança de som estrondoso em
vídeo
queremos lutar eles forçavam fazer um
impacto cada vez maior para que elas
possam voar cada vez mais alto e tem um
futuro melhor pra frente
14 semanas uma casa e essa casa um pouco
mais de uma pessoa e ensinam como fazer
e vai ensinando como realizar o
impossível começou a minar o show água
preta
nós viemos aqui consegui essa parte
técnica de imagem de credibilidade dessa
família
então joão fala foi ficando mais ou
menos há seis estacas que enquanto o dia
estava tirando nível para saber se estou
de salto na mesma altura
ele falou pra baixo quase nada
hoje só quero continuar em um falou que
tinha um trabalho de rotina dois metros
estava no shopping é nova assim tirar
aquilo vai virar peça a ele com ele
entende um pouco mais porque ele chegou
para mim e falou muito bem dela de seis
meses é um anjo
por isso não importa se a gente vai
considerar melhor para a gente ter essa
família a gente vai ter agilidade para
ele nesse momento
sentindo tudo aquilo que ele estava
fazendo
e foi aí que ele tinha uma porta edição
com a comunidade
não podemos dar menos tempo sempre
aquilo falando que você tem que
trabalhar 24 horas por dia sete dias por
semana de trabalho social falando com
vocês o acerto seja com a causa
mas eu tô falando que se você se
comprometer
durante o final de semana seja aquilo
deu seu melhor está em seu melhor para
entregar às pessoas que realmente
merecem expressiva recente passado a
chamada de unidades
o nosso maior problema
a cia até que a gente viu que só tendo
feito isso
nós batemos o pé e de ter usado a gente
vai focar e vai fazer o projeto
acontecer
foi aí que a gente decidiu montar um
projeto de saneamento ecológico uma
comunidade beira rio onde a nossa ideia
era usar o conhecimento mas não consegui
possam adaptar para modelos que a gente
estava precisando estando ecológica se
não precisavam ser um grande problema
a nova unidade o papel da língua
esse projeto é a loja vai ser a
revolução a cidade
na prática é totalmente outro
a gente começou a 22 metros de
profundidade artística falou muito mais
real a gente falar quase nada
moradores chegaram a pedir a muita gente
a habilidade pelo pecado a gente está
aqui no feriado da quinta feira para
poder construir um pouco da gente e ele
não está bem embolado chegou e deu para
ajudar em tudo que tem aqui hoje dão boa
demais e hoje de manhã
o processo após e assim gostaria de
dizer pra vocês se transformou em todas
as comunidades
até hoje só que esse seria a maior
mentira do projeto de subnutrição
infantil que eu fiz um parquinho que a
gente conseguiu quase nada de possuir
diretamente no máximo mil pessoas
indiretamente da comunidade diferente
aqui hoje cinco lições pra vocês vieram
transformar o bairro que você seja muito
muito muito mais lições para aprender
meu sonho é que foi o único candidato à
sua contribuição para mudar o mundo em
um lugar melhor e é isso